the aftermath of a shooting attack in
central tel aviv
a gunman arrived at this bar spraying
bullets more than a dozen people were
rushed to hospital
i was heading north and as we were
passing by a bar shot started outside i
saw the window shattering suddenly
people started running and i felt back
pain i did not know there was an injury
i was just walking and then i felt a lot
of blood i saw blood
diesengoff street is usually busy with
people visiting its bars and cafes
by the end of first evening it was full
of security forces you can see right
behind us a restaurant families and
friends were sitting having a supper and
drinks and all of a sudden the
terrorists came over and shot them shot
10 innocent
people
and
injured them unfortunately two of them
were
murdered
israel was already on its highest alert
this was the fourth attack within the
country in recent weeks all of them
appeared to have been carried out by
individuals no palestinian group claimed
a responsibility for any of them
it's understood that neither the
palestinian leadership nor israel wanted
escalation right now in the
long-standing conflict here
but as in the past even when no one's
interested in escalation things can
suddenly spiral out of control perhaps
sooner rather than later for israeli
prime minister naftali bennett who said
he won't engage in peace talks with the
palestinians he's trying to hold
together a fragile coalition which has
just lost its parliamentary majority the
pressure that's sure to fall on him to
adopt tougher measures towards
palestinians could now weaken and divide
his government further
john holman al jazeera west jerusalem